yeah your frog shows me his most popular
gun on sale an israeli-made weapon for
Israelis a nod to nationalism at a cost
of liter over a thousand dollars but
since January's attacks by Palestinians
against Israelis his classes to qualify
for Iran's license are in demand
this
two three weeks it's up double
entrepreneur a lot a lot of religious of
Orthodox yeah
and you're trying to hoping that
there'll be a fast track of the amount
of time it takes to get to life I hope
it is going to be more soon because it's
now it's urgent
yayu's clients range from high profile
politicians to settlers living illegally
in the occupied West Bank
but now some Ultra Orthodox Israelis say
they have no choice but to arm
themselves even though it contradicts
their religious beliefs and the
government hopes to bring in measures to
Fast Track that process to just 45 days
I've grown up in an area that's attacked
with everything from stones to
explosions my wife was against guns but
after the synagogue attack she changed
her mind I always rely on God but now I
need to make sure I can protect myself
Israel's security cabinet has already
approved measures to make it easier to
carry guns the driving force is a
controversial Minister convicted of
racism against Arabs
Israel's national security minister Ben
gevis says he wants more guns on the
streets and in fact he's already
instructed the Firearms licensing
department to increase those new permits
from 2000 to 10 000 a month that's a
rise by 400 percent
owning a gun in Israel isn't easy though
there are required medical checks proof
of a clean criminal record and even gun
safety tests but anti-gun campaigners
are warning that more guns will only
increase violence especially between
Israelis and Palestinians as people
might take the law into their own hands
it's not the Public's role to prevent
attacks it's the police's role and the
police should be focusing on that rather
than on fast-tracking licenses thank you
carries a personal weapon and we've seen
him documented and just threatening
Palestinian he didn't like in the
parking lot
according to the government
155 000 Israelis only legal personal
firearm but that figure is likely to
rise drastically that's on top of the
weapons owned by security forces and
police that can carry their service
weapons off duty the United Nations has
warned that more guns on the streets
here can only be a recipe for more
deaths and hate crimes
Al Jazeera give out their settlement in
the occupied West Bank